And we are going to kick this off with a little quiz.
So let's assume that we have an algorithm with a running time of 2^n  n², not O(2^n)n²,
but really 2^n  n².
You can add any constant you wan if that makes you happy but not so the point of this quiz here.
And now we're going to look at an algorithm that is 10 times faster,
so it has a running time of 2^nn²/10.
And if you think about it, finding an algorithm that is 10 times faster is actually huge in practice.
So imagine for example that whenever you start your computer,
it would start 10 times faster than it does now--a huge improvement,
but what I now want to show you is that such a huge improvement
is virtually useless when you're dealing with exponential time.
So assume for example that for this algorithm here, we have a computer
where the maximum input size that it can handle is 30, what I would like to know from you now
is if we run this algorithm which is 10 times faster, huge improvement on the same machine
what is the maximum input size we can handle then.
And I would like you to give me your answer here in this box.